cela fait maintenant sept ans que je
fais des vidéos sur cette chaîne youtube
vous n'allez pas voir ma gueule comme un
peu en cet or j'ai appris énormément de
choses comment avoir des abonnés comment
faire des vu comment avoir un corps
séduisant non c'est pas tellement ça
aujourd'hui je vais partager mon savoir
avec vous dans une vidéo intitulée
comment apprécier la pièce de théâtre de
texte non comment devenir youtuber
célèbre première astuce les amis premier
conseil c'est quelque chose
d'indéniables foutez vous de la qualité
de vos vidéos mais c'est parce qu'avant
de voir vos vidéos qu'est ce qu'on va
voir une miniature et un titre et oui et
si ça ça n'arrive pas à convaincre la
personne alors votre vidéo n'ira jamais
jusqu'à ses yeux comment bien travaillé
son titre sa miniature c'est très simple
si vous n'avez pas trop d'un spi vous
pouvez suivre la technique oif pour la
miniature pourquoi vous me demandez vous
car il s'agit l'abréviation de oued
qu'on trouverait d'art au showcase et je
sais j'ai pas mis toutes les lettres
dans l'aviation ça n'a aucun sens vous
le savez cette recette marche à tous les
coups pour jouer à un jeu vidéo à
l'impasse au teint peut on à cela pas
des halles
ça a du sens dans youtube games a du
sens vous allez alors faire un contour
blanc autour du lapin et des elle met
une flèche rouge vers celui ci et
ajoutez votre tête avec une expression
de choquer de l'autre côté de l'image
c'est pas trop mal c'est pas dégueu mais
qu'en est il du titre qu'est-ce qui vous
captivent le plus cela pas un désert ou
alors cela pas des ailes ou alors cela
pas des ailes ou alors cela pas déjà et
bien c'est une bonne chose nous sommes
d'accord pour faciliter la chose
n'hésitez pas à faire un shooting photo
de vous même faisant différentes
expressions ça va vous servir pendant
deux trois ans il vous aurait plus
besoin
just attention à pamiers entre temps
parce que ça va commencer à se griller
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
vidéo nous allons aujourd'hui parler
vidéo et n'oubliez pas de toujours
mettre votre visage sur les miniatures
je veux que les gens ne voient que ça en
ouvrant youtube
savez vous vous avez déjà vu les visages
que vous voyez dans vos rêves car votre
cerveau n'est pas capable de concevoir
des visages qui n'a pas vu auparavant je
veux que les rêves des gens soient
remplies de vos visages ok vous croisez
une dame et à votre visage vous croisez
un vieux il a beau visage vous croisez
un chien il a beau visage c'est à ça que
ça sert annie pu les cerveaux des gens à
lézinnes deuxième astuces n'oubliez
jamais ce pourquoi vous avez commencé à
faire de youtube l'adulte si les op
s'enchaînent et que les gens vous
soupçonne d'être un vendu le paniqué par
vous aurait encaissé assez d'argent pour
acheter de faux avis sur des sites de
merde sur des excellents six de ces avis
positif des crédibiliseront la minorité
d'avis négatifs qu'il aura sur votre
vidéo ces gens vont alors se remettre en
question à voir des jours voire des
semaines douloureuse en se demandant
pourquoi il pense différemment des
autres pourquoi ne suivent pas la masse
et tout ça grâce à votre intelligence et
la troisième astuces buvez une bonne
bouteille de saint pellegrino chaque
matin vont tourner ses délicieuses but
pétillante vous permettront d'avoir les
idées claires et de produire de belles
vidéos quatrième astuces un autre truc
que j'ai remarqué depuis tout ce temps
c'est l'importance de garder la même
coupe de cheveux du début à la fin alors
oui si vous avez commencé youtube très
jeune vous êtes un peu pénalisé on va
pas se mentir mais si vous avez commencé
un peu plus vieux comme antoine daniel
ça passe très bien en découvrant
youtuber pour la première fois on
ressent un film particulier envers sa
coupe de cheveux les mois et les années
vont passer vous allez changer mais
votre coupe de cheveux va rester là même
en retournant sur nos vidéos l'abonné va
donc ressentir une nouvelle fois ce
feeling particulier qui va lui rappeler
la fois il avait découvert cette coupe
de cheveux des années auparavant il est
donc destinée sans même s'en rendre
compte est accro à votre coupe de
cheveux et avoir une dose d'endorphines
monumentale à chaque vidéo de vous
pourquoi je gardais la même coupe depuis
des années c'était pas par plaisir
c'est par stratégie nombreux sont les
youtuber qui ont compris ça mais ne
veulent pas partager le secret
contrairement à moi les [ __ ] de plus
vous serez beaucoup plus facilement
reconnaissable dans la rue le nombre de
photos vous prendre avec vos femmes va
considérablement augmenter et cela est
très bon pour votre égo et pour devenir
un gros fils de 5e astuces les
commentaires négatifs vont arriver en
même temps que le succès et oui tout le
monde ne peut pas vous aimez même si
vous êtes s'entassent tic les
commentaires et de vos blesse mais ce
n'est rien à côté des critiques
constructives qui part de la vérité et
qui vous frappe en plein coeur pas de
panique vous êtes sur la bonne vidéo
j'ai la solution cliquer sur l'onglet
communauté cliquez ensuite sur l'onglet
paramètres de
notez ajouter des modérateurs qui
pourront supprimer les commentaires
négatifs avant que vous les voyez finies
les mauvaises journées à penser à ces
mauvais jugement en scrollant vers le
bas vous passerez devant tous les
utilisateurs banni de votre chaîne wahou
ils sont nombreux mais l'encadré qui
nous intéresse et l'encadrer des mots
bloqué marqué dans cet encadré tous les
maux qui est susceptible de contenir une
critique négative
j'aime pas c'est nul pourri naze tu as
changé
bof moyens bisous grâce aux filtres et
au modérateur les critiques négatives ne
vous atteindront plus jamais vous serez
alors réconforter dans les dés que vous
êtes le meilleur
le plus beau est le meilleur créateur de
la plateforme youtube félicitations
sixième à tous si malgré tout vous
perdez votre confiance en vous ça peut
arriver on a tous des mauvais jours
regardez une compilation de vous qui
rigolaient vraiment il m'a fallu cinq
ans pour trouver la solution et c'est
juste après ça que ma barbe s'est mise à
pousser une réaction d'égocentrisme
surpuissante aura lieu dans votre
cerveau et vous redonnerez immédiatement
confiance en vous vous êtes le meilleur
ne l'oubliez pas attention tout de même
à ne pas vous surprendre le rire de vous
même guerrier
[Rires]
ou alors peut-être que vous rirez de
vous même crié de vous même guéri 7e
astuces le fait de copier un autre est
totalement diaboliser on appelle ça le
plagiaire vous n'avez plus d'idées plus
de créativité
ne vous en faites pas chercher sur
youtube une chaîne espagnole ou anglaise
mais pas trop connu il ne faudrait pas
que le public français la connaissent
commençait alors à copier coller ces
vidéos sans aucun problème si votre
public commencent à s'en rendre compte
ne paniquez pas référez-vous à l'astuce
numéro 5
ça marche à tous les coups et c'est la
huitième astuces ça va vous paraître
loufoque mais n'hésitez pas à péter en
pleine vidéo
cela montre que vous êtes détendu et que
l'ambiance est bon enfant
aussi vous abonner et verront leur
message oseriez-vous péter devant autre
chose que de très bons amis
non alors si vous pétez devant vos
abonnés cela montre que vous les
considérez comme de bons amis dû s'en
rendre compte et vous aimerez encore
plus 9e institut
quand les gens commenceront à se lasser
de vous mais pas de votre coupe de
cheveux comme on l'a dit il leur faudra
un nouveau visage un nouveau
représentant de votre chaîne adopter un
animal comme on l'a fait c'est très
important pour réussir quoi de mieux
qu'un animal pour incarner le renouveau
de votre chaîne un chien un chat un peu
gâchis bas peu importe cela montrera que
vous aimez les animaux
si vous aimez les animaux vous aimez la
nature si vous aimez la nature vous êtes
une bonne personne
n'hésitez pas à ouvrir un compte
instagram ans on nous aime pratiquer le
placement de produits de manière à
rentabiliser le cou de l'animal 10e
astuces n'hésitez pas à aller faire
votre pub sur d'autres chaînes défaite
l'a intelligemment commencer votre
commentaire en vantant la vidéo j'ai
adoré ton court métrage bravo c'est trop
vague et pourrait s'agir d'un spam que
vous mettez sur toutes les vidéos qui
joue de mieux en mieux la comédie et les
blacks sont fluides et naturels
à ce moment précis et où l'on croira que
vous êtes un viewer sincère et pas mal
intentionnés vous en profiterez alors
pour vous diriger les gens vers votre
chaîne youtube car vous êtes le meilleur
je fais moi aussi des courts métrages
sur ma chaîne
à ce moment précis ça fait beaucoup trop
pub il faut montrer que notre intention
est bonne est pas méchante que vous êtes
à la recherche de quelque chose de
significatif et pas de chiffres
n'hésitez pas à venir me dire ce que
vous en pensez pour que je m'améliore
bingo les gens auront envie de jouer les
chevaliers blancs et devenir vous
réconforter dans l'idée que vous êtes le
meilleur
mais ce qu'ils savent pas c'est que vous
êtes le meilleur 11e astuces vous
connaissez très bien les pseudos des
gens qui ont beaucoup de clics vous
savez qu'en utilisant le pseudo de gens
connus vous allez pouvoir ramener une
partie de leur communauté sur votre
vidéo votre frère a une barbe et des
lunettes
mon frère et cyprien non qu'est-ce qu'on
va dire mon frère et cyprien vous tuez
un ennemi surfe en haïti il se trouve
qu'il s'appelle amis xoom
attendez je tu habites saab sur ford ait
12e astuces personne ne peut savoir le
fonctionnement exact de l'algorithme de
youtube pour quelles raisons mais thil
telle et telle vidéo en avant et bien
nous ne le savons pas mais tout le monde
suppose que c'est un mélange de witch
time qu'est ce que le coach times quel
pourcentage de la vidéo va être regardé
en moyenne par une personne qui est
tombée sur cette vidéo exemple je fais
une vidéo 10 minutes en moyenne les gens
regardent seulement deux minutes de
cette vidéo assez mauvais mais comment
faire pour tricher forcer les gens à
garder votre vidéo jusqu'au bout bien
qu'elle soit de piètre qualité
regardez ce que nos fils de [ __ ] c'est
non bien sûr que non plus subtil plus
malins soyez malins les réseaux sociaux
chers amis fait croire à l'utilisateur
qu'il est une surprise à la fin de la
vidéo et qu'il a tout intérêt à la voir
car est importante
bonjour les amis je viens de sortir une
nouvelle vidéo regardez la bien jusqu'au
bout il ya une petite surprise
jusqu'au bout est ce que le nombre de
commentaires ne reflètent pas aussi la
qualité d'une vidéo et donc la mise en
avant du youtube de ces dernières et
bastille alors fait sûrs que vous les
lisez tous n'hésitez pas à commenter la
vidéo je suis en train de lire tous vos
commentaires et ça me fait très plaisir
je les lis tout ils sont tous là je suis
en train de tous les lire alors
n'hésitez pas vous est si intelligent
mais peut-être que l'algorithme se base
aussi sur le nombre de j'aime d'une
vidéo et on n'oublie pas le petit pouce
bleus 1 pour soutenir le pouce bluff ou
alors qu'il se passe autour de fois où
la vidéo a été partagée qu'on est un bon
abonnés on partage la vidéo 1 sur les
réseaux on la partage
vous venez d'atteindre 10 millions
d'abonnés
bravo et maintenant